joe jonas a pas cédé et sa femme étaient
un peu maltraité par tirer sur lui il
est invité dans salut les terriens avec
keira buisson et sa femme anne nivat est
il n'avait pas vraiment apprécié
l'accueil souvenez-vous alors oui même
bar puisqu il n'a quand même pas dit le
principal en ce qui me concerne c'est
que ma fonction c'est pas être femme 2
au malawi pour tous les autres il est
bien rappelé tom va aller là c'est la
fin de ce nom et annie va vous venez pas
ce que vous avez écrit un livre aussi
qui s'appelle dans quelle france on vit
j'aimerais ça fait très bien quel
éditeur leur métier c'est d'aller voir
sur le terrain bien sûr mais non vous
allez faire un tour de france et
regardez vous avez choisi de visiter
civile montluçon laval
evreux lons le saunier lent et pour
finir ajaccio
mais à part ça je suis un reporter de
guerre mais bien sûr ça voyage à qui
revient sur une villa ça l'amour il est
très drôle on aime beaucoup alors au
micro hier des grandes gueules
il est revenue sur 7 sur cette anecdote
sur ce passage et il a pas bien digéré
notre ami jean jacques qu'on aime bien
aussi
dix ans qui a pas été très corrects dans
cette affaire incorrecte du tout même
parce que l'enregistrement a été diffusé
rediffusé le lendemain très bien mais ça
a été accompagnée de commentaires
ensuite commentaires de baffie
commentaire j'ai pas beaucoup aimé cette
inélégance c'est le piège peut-être des
émissions a rejeté notre faute
notre faute d'être allé obtenir les plus
chères dit sans le dire n y aura plus
attention djamen non j'aime pas
l'inélégance alors tirèrent buisson a
répondu ah il a répondu il a répondu
chez jean marc morandini il dit la
veille de sa venue dans l'émission anne
nivat m'a appelé trois fois pour me
demander de ne pas oublier de dire
qu'elle est grand reporter de guerre
j'avais prévu de le faire mais tom villa
qui passe en début d'émission n'était
pas briefé il ne l'a pas dire alors anna
alors exigé qu'on arrête le tournage
pour que tom reviennent le dire ce qu'il
a fait et le lendemain anm a demandé de
couper son pétage de plomb et de
réintégrer le moment où tom est revenue
dire grand reporter de guerre voilà
et voilà jean jacques est fâché contre
moi quelle histoire
ma bonne dame voilà où thierry voilà
qu'on embrasse aussi fort alors
franchement c'est gentil après après
auch pau combien de gens là que si sa
femme a été vexé qui niveau là les
souris
elle a pas été maltraités elle a été
malmenée cet homme villa qui est un
humoriste absolument génial voilà c'est
vraiment absolument isabelle a raison
c'est un problème d'ego c'est un
concours de coqs en fait et après quand
elle est allée sur d'autres bateaux pour
s'expliquer de ce problème là elle n'a
pas du tout parlé sont de son travail de
reporter de guerre ni de son livre elle
était juste focus sur ses rares dix au
sentiment je trouve que pour le coup
c'est un peu ridicule
ouais bon ça va aller c'est juste
qu'elle a un peu donné le bâton pour se
faire battre sur ce coup là parce
qu'elle est venue faire la promotion de
son livre avec son époux jean jacques
bourdin qui lui n'avait pas écrit le
livre donc en l'occurrence elle s'est
servie un peu la notoriété de jean
jacques bourdin
donc c'est normal aussi un peu qu'on la
qualifie de femme de jean jacques
dussart grand reporter en plus vraiment
c'est vrai mais elle n'a pas besoin
hannibal a pas besoin de la notoriété
jeu rock band en abondance et vinoodh
pas forcément raison mais c'est
quelqu'un d'éminemment respectable
évidemment la connaissais pas les grands
arrières donc taisez-vous aux cruches ça
va c'est pas ça leur passe on oubliera
effet ça veut dire pour lui donc ça veut
dire qu'on est sympa comme tout